vamos a imaginarnos que tú eres el
filósofo de la antigüedad o el
matemático de la antigüedad
y tú has descubierto los números
negativos entonces tú sabes que para que
los números negativos tengan sentido con
todas las demás cosas que has construido
hasta ahora necesitas que un número
negativo multiplicado por un número
positivo te dé un número negativo o en
el orden contrario número positivo por
un número negativo también te voy a dar
un número negativo y además además tú
sabes que un número negativo por un
número negativo debe darte un número
positivo para que todo sea congruente
para que se respete por ejemplo la ley
de la distributiva y dady cosas así así
que bien eso es lo que sabes pero no no
se te hace que esto tenga mucho sentido
quizás quizás quieras encontrar una
razón más profunda de por qué esto tiene
que ser cierto así que bien lo que hace
es podría hacer es comenzar a pensar en
la multiplicación habitual digamos por
ejemplo consideremos el número 2 x
número
2 x 3 y esto que es pues la
multiplicación la pueden pensar
simplemente como sumar repetida en este
caso 2 x 3
es completamente equivalente a tres más
tres donde tengo todos tres es tengo dos
números 3 sumo el 3 consigo mismo dos
veces o también podría simplemente decir
dos por tres es lo mismo que dos más dos
más dos en este caso tengo tres 12
tengo tres números dos
pero no importa cuál sea la que elijas
siempre te da el mismo resultado te da
el número 6 entonces vamos a ver qué
pasa si ahora transforma nuestros
números en un número negativo bien así
que vamos a considerar qué sucede si
cambio esto por 2 x
menos
2 por menos 3 y bien si hago lo mismo
que acá arriba puedo decir ah pues esto
simplemente es dos veces menos 3 así que
es menos 3
- 3
una vez menos
dos veces perfecto pero también podría
ser lo mismo que acá solo que aquí tengo
un menos y podría de hecho pensar que
esto es en realidad 2 positivo más 2 más
2 porque esto en realidad es un 3
positivo ahora tengo un 3 negativo así
que podría pensar que en vez de sumar
los dos voy a restar los así que voy a
escribir esto como
en los dos
- 2 una vez
- 2
dos veces y finalmente menos dos y de
nuevo de nuevo noten que tengo tres
veces el número dos sólo que como ahora
mi 3 es negativo lo estoy restando pero
no importa cuál de las dos opciones
elija si esto de restar menos tres menos
tres o menos 2 - 2 - 2 siempre obtengo
el resultado menos 6 así que ya nos
sentimos más cómodos con esta primera
parte vamos a explorar un poco la
segunda posibilidad muy bien pues qué
pasa ahora si consideramos
si consideramos
si consideramos menos 2
- 3
qué sucede en esta situación y de nuevo
no podría ser de dos modos ahora lo voy
a hacer de este modo primero
y lo que quiero hacer es decir pues acá
tenía 2 x menos 3 y entonces lo que hice
fue restar algo tres veces así que ahora
ahora lo que voy a hacer es restar algo
tres veces menos algo menos algo menos
algo y que es ese algo pues ese algo es
menos 2 así que menos
menos
2 estoy restando menos 2 3 veces ahora
bien nosotros sabemos que restar un
negativo equivale a sumar algo es como
si si alguien tiene una deuda y de
repente le quitas esa deuda pues
entonces en realidad lo que está pasando
es que le estás dando dinero le estás
sumando algo ok entonces también podría
hacerlo de este lado y para analizar
esto quiero que noten que esto esto de
acá arriba
esto es lo mismo que
- 3
+ - 3
simplemente los estoy tomando dos veces
así que ahora que tengo menos 2 también
puedo pensar que aquí hay un más y
entonces es dos veces sumar algo ahora
que tengo el menos va a ser restar algo
dos veces así que va a ser menos algo
- algo y que es ese algo pues es menos 3
así que es menos menos
tres y menos tres así que esto de nuevo
que restar un negativo equivale a sumar
algo así que esto equivale a 33 y en
cualquiera de las dos situaciones
obtengo el número 6
y así que ustedes ahora ya están muy
contentos porque ahora no solo es cierto
que esto se vale porque se necesita para
que todas las operaciones la propiedad
distributiva la propiedad asociativa
todas esas cosas tengan validez sino que
también ya tienen intuición al respecto
de por qué es cierto y cómo se relaciona
con la noción o una de las nociones
habituales de la multiplicación